la recta numérica doble muestra que una
tortuga marina puede nadar 36 metros en
4 segundos y aquí tenemos esta recta
numérica doble que nos muestra en estas
rectas numéricas bueno nos muestran la
distancia en metros que puede recorrer
una tortuga en un tiempo dado por
ejemplo cuando tenemos 0 segundos
la tortuga no ha recorrido nada tenemos
0 metros y bueno por ejemplo acá cuando
tenemos 4 segundos
la tortuga ha recorrido 36 metros por lo
tanto si observas cualquier valor en
esta recta numérica por ejemplo este de
aquí donde el tiempo es igual a un
segundo esa misma marca me va a dar la
distancia que recuerde la tortuga en
este primer segundo
en dos segundos bueno tenemos esta marca
de acá etcétera y nos preguntan de
acuerdo con la razón que se muestra en
la recta numérica doble cuántos metros
puede nadar una tortuga marina en tres
segundos pausa el vídeo y piensa en ello
recuerdan para saber cuántos metros
pueden nadar una tortuga marina en tres
segundos es decir nos vamos a fijar
justo aquí en tres segundos basándonos
en estas dos rectas numéricas
necesitamos saber cuál es este dato de
aquí es decir saber cuánto valen esta
marca es lo que necesitamos bueno
podemos encontrar esta distancia usando
razones porque sabemos que la razón del
tiempo en segundos a la distancia en
metros serán de 4 segundos a 36
la razón de segundos a metros es de 436
ahora si queremos encontrar esta razón
por un segundo lo que tenemos que hacer
es dividir entre 4 voy a dividir entre 4
y voy a obtener la razón equivalente
para un segundo y también voy a hacer lo
mismo para el 2 metros si divido el 36
entre 4 voy a obtener la cantidad de
metros que nada en un segundo y bueno 36
entre 4 y 9 entonces tenemos una razón
equivalente de 19 ahora si queremos
saber cuántos metros nadar a mi tortuga
marina en 3 segundos
bueno este aquí es el tiempo en tres
segundos lo que tenemos que hacer es
multiplicar esta razón por tres entonces
voy a multiplicar esta razón por tres de
tal manera que uno por tres me den
en tres segundos mi tortuga nadar a am 9
por 3 así que déjame ponerlo 9 por 3 lo
cual es 20 7
por lo tanto tengo otra razón
equivalente de 327 eso quiere decir que
en esta marca de aquí mi tortuga me
habrá nadado 27 metros o dicho de otra
manera ya podemos contestar la pregunta
cuántos metros puede nadar una tortuga
marina entre segundos bueno puede nadar
27 metros
muy bien hagamos otro ejercicio dice la
recta numérica doble muestra cuántos
modelos de trenes puede construir irene
en una semana y podemos ver que en la
semana 0
irene no construido ningún tren y en la
semana 1 ha construido 9 trenes y nos
preguntan cuál tabla representa la tasa
a la que se construyen modelos de trenes
y aquí tengo estas dos tablas así que
pausa el vídeo e intenta encontrar la
respuesta una vez más cada semana puede
construir 9 trenes eso lo podemos
escribir como una razón de 1 a 9 déjame
ponerlo con este color de 1
bueno si observamos estas dos tablas
necesitaremos encontrar una en donde se
conserve siempre una razón de 19 veamos
5 y 45 bien esta es una razón de 19 para
ir de 1 a 5 lo que hicimos fue
multiplicar por 5 y para ir de 9 a 45 lo
que hicimos fue multiplicar también por
5 así que están también es una razón
equivalente de 195 a 45 o tal vez otra
forma de pensar lo es que 45 es nueve
veces 5 así que si multiplico esto por 9
me da 45 bien vamos a ver el siguiente
caso 12 semanas a 108 trenes otra vez 12
por 9 es 108
así que también este escenario
corresponde ahora en el último escenario
han pasado 26 semanas
irene ha construido 234 trenes veamos
26 por 10 es 260 y si a eso le quitamos
26 me da bien en efecto me da 234 así
que también en este caso estoy
multiplicando por 9 26 por 9 es 234 por
lo tanto en todos estos casos la razón
de semanas a trenes es de 19 así que se
ve bien voy a seleccionarla para estar
completamente seguros revisemos la otra
tabla para ver que en efecto exista
alguna fila que no tenga una razón de 19
en la primera bueno observa la razón de
semanas a trenes no es de 19 es de 9 a 1
recuerdan los trenes que hacían eran 9
veces la cantidad de semanas no al revés
aquí las semanas son 9 veces la cantidad
de trenes así que esta no es la opción
correcta
perfecto hagamos otro ejercicio la recta
numérica doble muestra cuántas bolas de
nieve pueden hacer jacobo y sus amigos
en un minuto aquí tenemos las dos rectas
numéricas dobles y dicen completa la
tabla para mostrar la misma información
que la recta numérica doble ok pausa el
vídeo e intenta llenar la tabla
bueno pensemos en la razón en este caso
la razón de los minutos a las bolas de
nieve es de 1 a 12
déjame escribirlo la razón de los
minutos a las bolas de nieve es de 1 a
otra forma de pensarlo es que hacen 12
bolas por cada minuto por lo tanto ya
podemos decidir que 12 bolas de nieve
las hace en un minuto de lujo ahora para
hacer 48 bolas de nieve necesitamos
multiplicar este 12 por 4 es decir
estamos multiplicando por cuatro por lo
tanto vamos a hacer lo mismo con los
minutos voy a multiplicar esto por
cuatro y voy a obtener cuatro minutos y
ahora para ir de un minuto a cinco
minutos lo que estoy haciendo es
multiplicarlo por cinco así que voy a
hacer lo mismo con las bolas de nieve
voy a multiplicar 12 por 5 para obtener
la cantidad de bolas de nieve que se
hacen en 5 minutos 12 por 5 es 60 y lo
hemos logrado estas razones 1 a 12 4 a
48 y 5 a 60 son equivalentes eso es todo
en este vídeo